تجارب كوريا النوويه تاثيرها لم يعد
سياسيا او عسكريا فقط بل باتت تهدد صحه
السكان دراسه صادره عن منظمه حقوقيه اوضحت
ان الاغذيه ومحاصيل الفطر او ما يعرف في
بعض المناطق العربيه بعش الغراب المزروعه
بالقرب من موقع للتجارب النوويه في كوريا
الشماليه تهدد صحه السكان في جميع انحاء
المنطقه والذين يستهلكون الفطر وتقول
الدراسه ان مئات الالاف من الاشخاص الذين
يعيشون بالقرب من منشاه بنجري للابحاث
والتجارب النوويه في اقصى شمال كوريا
الشماليه معرضون لخطر الاشعاعات المنبعثه
من الانفاق والتي تتسرب الى المياه
الجوفيه المستخدمه في الشرب وفي الري
مجموعه عمل العداله الانتقاليه في كوريا
الجنوبيه دعت الى اجراء فحوصات واختبارات
للاجئين الكوريين الشماليين الذين عاشوا
سابقا في تلك المنطقه وفقا لما ذكرته صح
البريطانيه